don't have a starter yet the pirates
will announce the starter tomorrow and
there's a called third strike we might
see mitch keller start tomorrow's game
and
two away
2-2 foul tips struck him out on the
inside slider brubacher looked dominant
in that first inning he struck out real
muto and harper facing aranola who's
coming in with a record of seven and six
a four point three seven era
the one-two offer
and check swing on the curveball he went
around and gavel is down on strikes
swag in a miss through a curve back to
back
curve balls to reynolds
[Applause]
1-2 from brubacher right there strike
three call sat with the bat on his
shoulder
[Applause]
the ground single to right
ball bounced to castro
six up six down for brubacher
[Applause]
and he does swinging a miss three
strikeouts for aaron that's 143 on the
season
ground ball to third and right at alec
baum
he guides it across the diamond so both
starting pitchers six up six down
and now a little shovel and yes he got
him jankowski
shovels to
brubacher well done
you were just mentioning what a good job
he does at getting the ball to the
pitcher
you can't be much
better and quicker and at the same time
he's fielding the ball he's already he's
pointing over there to make sure that
brubacher you know
keep going i'm gonna give you the ball
watch his left hand see like he's gonna
go go go i got it i got it
now nolan to shallow center field and
reynolds how about this defense
b-ray
spectacular catch she robs the pitcher
knoll overhead but the steel curtain d
that is sensational
newman with a big two-run double last
night put the pirates up seven nothing
the ball hit well out to right center
this one's heading toward the wall and
one hops on the wall castro's going to
score easily newman around second with
good speed heading to third and he
slides in with a triple give him a run
batted in and the pirates lead one to
nothing off the bat of kevin newman
that ball was hit with a lot of
authority i mean just absolutely
crushing that right center gap i mean
newman's not necessarily known for you
know his pop but that ball jumped off
his back joe i mean just a really good
swing on a ball running back over which
allows him to get that barrel in and
through and he just
worked it very well into that gap camel
went down on strikes his first time up
1-1 is popped up back of the drawn in
infield to shallow center jankowski
coming on and he slides can't get it
here comes newman scrambling into score
and the pirates lead two-nothing on that
ball that fell into no man's land with
that drawn in infield
i can't believe the center fielder got
that close i mean infield's playing in
it's not that far
into the grass in the outfield and
the the blonde headed wonder out there
in center field kind of came out of
nowhere he's playing really deep
i guess so he can come in on the ball to
maybe you know throw out newman if he
gets a fly ball and he made that play
really close two on nobody out for dd
gregorius
oh good work there to strike out
gregorius big time k number four for
brubacher aaron lined out his first time
up on a play by reynolds in center
diving play
out toward right center field and blanco
makes the catch tagging from third is
miller the throw to the plate is offline
and the fills are on the board
it's a 2-1 ball game and aaron nola gets
a sacrifice fly
love to see a pitcher take pride in what
he does at home plate
not just saying you know what i'm just
an out
help myself i'm going to help my ball
club
oh what fastball eighth to second
and on the first so
j.t brubacher gets a gigantic final out
jason shreve
again pitched last night
and good work by williams pinch hitter
as he walks to put two on for segura and
out comes derek shelton gonna
make a move here
not giving up very many hits opponent
batting average very low 217.
fly ball to center field and
that is brian reynolds
kyle keller
big final out
the stretch
the pitch
and that one is a called strike runner
off the back at first though back to
first and he's picked off
at first base by jt it was not a pick
off play he just saw nagowski
way too far off the bag and uh i don't
know if dagowski misread something there
but he was way off the back yeah he was
going and then stopped he got a huge
what
looked like a big break on it and just
decided about three steps into it
yeah i got to shut it down i don't have
it
bryce harper here in the overrated
chance which he normally hears he's old
for two of the walk
that one is spun over the head of real
muto softly into left center field jt's
around third heading for home he's gonna
score it's an rvi single for harper and
the phillies have tied it up at two
all right hart
they come up big
bad on the ball bat on the ball
38 rbis for harper
and he takes off
and a perfect throw from stallings
and so bryce harper is caught stealing
for the first time this season after
first 12 successful steals
that was a great throw
here's the set in the pitch we're gonna
swing the boundary right up third
backing up hayes fields that tough ball
and throws it across just in time to get
real muto for the out
good play by key brian hayes
and stratton allows two two out hits but
leaves him stranded and we go to the
bottom of the ninth inning ryan reynolds
will lead it off for the pirates they
need a run to win it phillies are 25 and
15 in the 40 games he's appeared in
and a fly ball to left center field
that's going to get down head toward the
wall cut off by jankowski reynolds into
second base head first dive
and a lead-off double on the bottom of
the ninth just a fastball center cut
down to middle gonna challenge reynolds
with the first pitch
[Music]
[Applause]
even though it was cut off there's no
way of keeping reynolds off second
jacob stallings with six walk-off hits
in his career dating back to 2016.
[Applause]
bounce toward third breaking for the
plates be safe
walk it off raise the jolly roger
stallings has done it again
on the great slide by reynolds
the buccos
defeat
the phillies
now they're looking at this they went to
new york
they're challenging it
so we'll have to wait oh we should have
curved our enthusiasm there well i think
he's safe well but you never know in
this day and age you know if the fans
were excited about the walk-off
initially now we'll have to wait and see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so the pirates do walk it off
and now the fans can get excited do it
all over again it's a double celebration
that's right